[Music]
on this saturday night the rising number
of coveted 19 cases in young ontarians
there's a massive spike in case numbers
and that's alarming it's concerning
why the province is hesitant to send
kids back to school a boeing jet
disappears after takeoff in
indonesia what happened to the aircraft
and the dozens of people on it
impeaching donald trump a second time
the person who's running executive
branch
is a deranged unhinged dangerous
president what it will take for
democrats to pull off this
unprecedented move and how canada could
speed up its conversion to electric cars
the money that was been made from fossil
fuels is going to have to be
channeled into the clean technologies
and the country
that's already doing it
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
colleen christie good evening thanks for
joining us we begin tonight in ontario
where new modeling
set to be released next week shows an
alarming spike of covet 19 cases in
young people
the province is now extending its free
child care program to include more
front-line workers as it considers
extending the school break even further
morgan campbell has our top story
tonight
zoom calls every day you know you have
to you get to ask questions you get
you know assigned work and it's not that
bad ten-year-old derrick ivils is
describing
his day in the life of online learning
he is one of many ontarians working and
learning from home
while the province grapples with more
than 3 thousand new cases of covet 19
for the sixth straight day there's a
massive spike
in case numbers and that's alarming it's
concerning ontario is reporting a nearly
120 percent increase
in the number of cases among school-aged
children which in part
is the reason why ontario's education
minister
has made the decision to keep students
in southern ontario
out of the classroom until at least
january 25th
the trend is problematic and we have to
take this seriously
the provincial government is expected to
present new modeling data
monday according to the minister 80
percent of ontario schools weren't
experiencing outbreaks
prior to the holiday break it is
believed that that spike in cases we are
currently seeing right now especially
among children
is a direct result of people gathering
during the holidays
something many medical professionals
across canada
have been warning about ultimately the
long-term goal is to keep schools open
but i think this is how we do it because
we don't want to open up the schools
and then shut them down again because
all these families are getting sick
but parents say they feel as if they
have been kept in the dark
i can take it you know just tell me the
truth so i know
what to expect and how i can plan
accordingly for my family
and are concerned about the quality of
education
online i can't lie it's definitely
hectic
i think most of it is just they're just
bored cooped up inside of a house
so they're all you know young kids are
just busy and they just can't sit in the
house
meantime ontario is planning to expand
the free
child care offered to front line workers
to include
several other forward-facing professions
morgan campbell global news toronto
in quebec tonight a month-long curfew
comes into effect as the province
smashes another
daily record for covet-19 cases quebec
logged more than
3 000 new cases today more than 1500 of
them in montreal
that's nearly double the number reported
on thursday
to curb the spread anyone out between 8
pm and 5
a.m could face fines ranging from one to
six thousand dollars
the province is imposing the curfew to
prevent gatherings
in a facebook post today premier
francois lugo says
it's all the small breaches of the rules
that feed the virus
more police are expected to be deployed
to crack down
on curfew breakers an indonesian
airliner went missing today shortly
after taking off from the country's
capital contact was lost
with sriwijaya air flight 182 just
four minutes from after taking off from
jakarta
search crews have discovered debris
floating in the water near the area
where it went off the radar
50 passengers and 12 crew members were
on board
as michael couture reports their
families are fearing the worst
even through their masks you can see the
anguish on the faces of family members
as they hear
the plane is missing yamanzai can no
longer keep in the pain
as he realizes his wife and three
daughters may be gone
i was supposed to pick them up he says
through tears this is my first daughter
i won't be able to meet them again
off the coast of jakarta the indonesian
national search and rescue agency combed
the waters of the java sea
looking for any sign of the airliner
later they were seen on shore examining
a body bag containing debris suspected
to be
from sirijaya air flight 182.
indonesia's transport minister isn't
sure what led to the apparent crash
but they are investigating all avenues
we are coordinating with the meteorology
climatology and geophysical agency
to find out what the weather conditions
were like at the time he says
heavy rain delayed departure but once
the plane did take off everything seemed
normal as you can see in this radar
tracker
four minutes later it veers off course
and drops
out of the sky
the head of the airline expressed sorrow
at a news conference but he insists the
plane
was fit to fly
there shouldn't have been any problem
and the maintenance report was also
fined says jefferson irwin johanna but
maintenance and safety
have been an issue in that part of the
world airline experts say the rapid
growth of the industry in southeast asia
has led to some corner cutting but again
because of the growth
and less experienced people their
records are not quite as unblemished as
that of north america or europe
now it's not clear what went wrong but
we do know it was a boeing 737.
in a statement the company acknowledged
the media report saying quote
our thoughts are with the crew
passengers and their families
this week boeing was ordered to pay 2.5
billion dollars u.s
to settle a criminal investigation into
two deadly 737
max plane crashes 346 people were killed
including
18 canadians and another incident could
impact consumer confidence i think
that's probably an overreaction
but it's something that people are going
to think about particularly the
non-frequent flyers that make a big part
of our flying public
meantime indonesian search and rescue
teams will continue to scour the debris
field from the air and
underwater hoping to find the plane's
flight data recorder
mike lacrouter global news
a 14 year old russian boy is the sole
member of his family to survive an
avalanche that struck a ski resort in
the country's arctic
more than 200 rescuers and volunteers
rushed to search for survivors after the
snow came crashing down early today
the boy dug out alive is being treated
in hospital for serious injuries
including frostbite
but the lifeless bodies of two adults
believed to be his parents
and an 18 month old child were also
pulled from the snow
officials say they aren't looking for
any other missing people
to the situation in the u.s now
democrats are swiftly
laying plans to impeach president trump
for a second time
if that happens he would be the first
president in american history
to hold that dubious distinction as
jennifer johnson explains the
proceedings could begin in a matter of
days
after surviving an attack on the capitol
house speaker nancy pelosi is on the
attack
putting forth an article of impeachment
against president donald trump
accusing him of incitement of
insurrection it could be introduced
monday
the person who's running executive
branch is a deranged
unhinged dangerous president of the
united states
we're going to walk down to the capitol
the article alleges trump's conduct
gravely endangered the security of the
united states
the president has now been silenced by
his favorite platform twitter
which permanently suspended his account
citing risk of further violence
the white house put out a statement
saying another impeachment trial
will only further divide the country a
second impeachment and a senate
conviction
would disqualify trump from running for
president in 2024
or ever holding any public office
outgoing senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell says the earliest the senate
could hold an impeachment trial
is january 19th trump's last full day in
office
democrats are encouraging the senate to
return sooner this is a president who
incited an attempted coup to
stop a the certification of the next
president united states to remain in
power
the first senate republican has now
called on the president to go
senator lisa murkowski saying i want him
to resign i want him out
he has caused enough damage invoking the
25th amendment removing the president
from
office has been discussed but white
house insiders say vice president mike
pence is unwilling to take that step
the deadly riot left five people dead
including capitol police officer brian
siknik
who was hit in the head with a fire
extinguisher only the fourth capital
officer to die in the line of duty and
the force's almost 200 year history
anti-trump protesters have set up camp
on the national mall
when democracy is under attack but trump
supporters are still here too
resurrection act is happening
more people from the pro-trump mob that
storm the capital are being arrested
including adam johnson pictured carrying
nancy pelosi's lectern
and jacob anthony chansley seen inside
the senate chamber
as police search for more rioters
officials are preparing for a massive
military presence on inauguration day
after the worst security breach at the
capitol since the war of 1812.
jennifer johnson global news washington
pundits and politicians are condemning
what happened this week but that's not
the case in some
corners of the internet president
trump's baseless claims of a stolen
election sparked online conspiracy
theories
and as mike armstrong explains
disinformation fueled the anger that led
to the storming of the capitol we're
going to walk down
to the capitol some have called this
the moment donald trump finally threw
the match
if police didn't expect what happened
next there are others who predicted it
emotions were running too high for too
long and political scientist matthew
lebo
says people should have seen it coming
this is where the country's been going
for years and this is where
where trump has been leading his crowds
certainly for the past few months they
are marching through now
the rhetoric since the november election
has been daily and
dangerous team trump claiming the
election had been stolen
pushing in fact multiple conspiracy
theories
there is no shredding of ballots going
on that's not real
in georgia the secretary of state is
pushed back and asked the president to
stop
i easily win warning about the tension
he was ratcheting up
and the possibility it could get someone
shot they don't get to steal it from us
we want our country back conspiracy
theories may have been the fuel for the
riots but they're also being used to
explain them away
whether it's allegations police
supported the mob or people arguing
infiltrators were responsible for the
violence most of the people that was in
the capitol
antifa they're doing the damage to make
our group look bad
now conspiracy theories have been around
basically forever but donald trump has
harnessed them like
few before they stole it they're thieves
part of it's been right-wing media
the other social media every
conspiratorial claim since birtherism
has been disseminated and amplified by
twitter and facebook
those who run the new media have
abdicated any civic responsibility in
any journalistic responsibility
and in that world that's a very
dangerous world to live in it's a very
dangerous world for democracy
now twitter and facebook have pushed
back this week but many say
it comes too late this is only happening
near the end of his term
they should have been braver bolder more
courageous
in limiting his disinformation long time
ago
you'll never take back our country with
weakness
now trump and his followers do have
options other social media apps like
parlor or telegram
they're growing specifically because
there's no gatekeeping
and they're harder to follow that's
probably in my view the danger
because for for us as researchers it's
very hard for uh
to monitor these personalized
private mobile apps the newer social
media are also
even more of an echo chamber where
misinformation is amplified
and less likely to be challenged as for
the solution
it took years to reach this point
experts say it will take
years to dig our way out mike armstrong
global news
montreal coming up next why canada's
vaccine rollout is moving
slower than in other countries
vaccines have been billed as the golden
ticket for a return to
normal life but canada's vaccine rollout
has been sluggish
prime minister justin trudeau has called
the rise in covet-19 cases across this
country
frightening and he's promised to pick up
the pace on vaccinations this week on
the west block our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stephenson
asks why canada is moving at a slower
pace than other countries and
what ottawa is prepared to do about it
mercedes
colleen the vaccine rollout is top of
mind for canadians
anxious to be able to hug their
grandparents go to concerts
or even just send their kids back to
school not to mention the small
businesses who have been suffering
under lockdown measures and the massive
costs of ongoing federal programs
designed to support canadians
and while the liberal government has
made big promises on vaccines having
bought the highest number of vaccines
per capita
of any country in the world the pace of
that rollout is being criticized
by the opposition by some premiers and
by doctors and scientists who say
it's too slow with lives on the line
canada lags behind
several other countries in the number of
people being vaccinated
including the us uk and israel canada
has vaccinated fewer than 250
000 people while israel has vaccinated
more than 1.5 million
and the uk has vaccinated over a million
as well
there are reports that israel paid a
premium to get access to vaccines
faster i asked minister leblanc if
canada is willing to do the same
leblanc wouldn't disclose specifics but
said the cost
will be no obstacle we've said from the
beginning price
will not be a barrier for canada getting
as quickly as possible all of the doses
we need
so those companies know that it's not
some other country offering
some premium that's going to change the
delivery date to canada
we've said and we've successfully
negotiated with them
based on an extremely aggressive
procurement strategy
on friday federal officials said canada
will scale up its vaccine supply by the
end of february
but the provinces say they are running
out now with ontario premier doug
ford saying the province will run out of
vaccines within the next week
a claim minister leblanc disagreed with
if you knew you had
200 000 in a week how
sincere is it to say oh my god at the
end of the week we don't have any more
vaccines
of course you don't because there are
more coming next week and then the week
after there are even more
we'll have more on canada's slow vaccine
progress and what the government is
planning to do about it
sunday on the west block colleen
mercedes-stephenson in ottawa thanks
mercedes
a regimental funeral was held this
afternoon to honor a fallen calgary
police officer
the memorial for sergeant andrew harnett
was private but a procession took place
to allow
the public to pay tribute the 14-year
veteran of the force
died on new year's eve after being
struck by a vehicle during a traffic
stop
the 37 year old leaves behind his wife
chelsea who
is pregnant with their first child two
people are now facing first-degree
murder charges in connection with
harnett's death
just ahead the uk reaches a covet
tipping point
and the queen and prince philip received
their first vaccines
you're watching global national
the united kingdom has reached a new
grim pandemic milestone
more than 81 000 people have now died
from the virus
that's the highest death toll in europe
the uk
is also the first european country to
surpass 3 million
confirmed covet 19 cases the surge in
cases is
overwhelming hospitals right across the
uk many intensive care units are now
at or over capacity doctors are warning
the pressure on the health care system
is likely to worsen
in the coming weeks the country's
vaccine rollout has reached the royal
family
94 year old queen elizabeth has received
her first dose
along with her 99 year old husband
phillip a royal doctor administered the
shots at windsor castle
it's unclear which vaccine was given to
the couple whose ages put them in
britain's
second priority group royal sources say
the private matter was made public to
prevent speculation
india will begin the world's largest
vaccination drive in one week with the
goal of reaching
300 million people by july two
nationwide dry runs were done to prepare
for the mammoth rollout
the country has approved two covid19
vaccines
one by astrazeneca and oxford university
the other by
india's bahart biotech india's
population exceeds
1.3 billion with 10 million covet 19
cases
so far up next the electric car
revolution and the one country that's
leaving canada in its
dust
norway has become the first country in
the world where the majority of vehicles
sold are electric
in fact the nordic nation aims to
eliminate all gasoline car sales within
just
four years redmond shannon looks at how
canada compares and why
buying electric isn't always a simple
decision
norway peaceful progressive and
beautiful
a country that tends to find itself at
the top of all the good lists
so it's no surprise that norwegians now
buy more battery electric vehicles
than all other car types combined in
fact in 2020 only
17 of passenger vehicle sales were
gasoline or diesel
the most popular model in norway
in 2020 was the audi e-tron
and that is not a cheap car either in
in canada or in the uk or in norway
it's mostly down to big financial
incentives including an exemption from
import tax and the 25 sales tax
no annual road tax and large discounts
on tolls and ferries they can also use
bus lanes which is starting to become a
problem
a daughter of a friend of mine she said
to her father
look father there's a bus in the tesla
lane
it also helps that norway is rich its
wealth ironically coming from its
fossil fuel exports but in the end
that's what's going to have to happen on
an enormous scale
the money that was been made from fossil
fuels is going to have to be channeled
into
the clean technologies of the future
that we need one criticism of electric
cars
is the environmental impact of large
batteries
there needs to be a multi-pronged
strategy led by governments but also
participating by businesses
that mean that we can address the
sourcing issues
for the metals that are essential to go
into
battery electric vehicles in canada
where suvs and pickups dominate
electric vehicles make up less than
three percent of sales
those bigger vehicles have been a bit
slower coming on the electric side but
they're
they're they're coming quickly ottawa
offers a five thousand dollar incentive
quebec adds an eight thousand dollar
rebate
on top of that the trajectory is is
clearly there that's happening
the automakers are ramping up for that
you can see the sales trajectory is
going in that direction
gm says it wants to overtake tesla and
sell a million e-cars in north america
by
2025 but by then norway will have
eliminated
all gasoline vehicle sales canada's goal
is to do the same
by 2040 redmond shannon global news
london
and that is global national for this
saturday i'm colleen christie tonight's
your canada
is fireman's park in niagara falls
ontario
we love to see your part of our
beautiful country email your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope you'll join us
again tomorrow have a great night
you